I've been very fortunate and deliberate
to surround myself with good people
throughout my life
but I've recently gotten to sort of
observe not close to me but
nearby somebody that could be classified
as a sociopath yeah and and uh and a
narcissist like I I don't want to use
those psychological terms but just I
it's like oh people you know come with
different biology too so it's not just
like the the trauma you might experience
in your early life and all the Deep
complexity that leads uh all the Deep
complexity that leads to the the
psychology that you are have as an adult
but it's also the biology come with the
the nature that you might not just have
the
the machine that can empathize deeply
with the experience of others or maybe a
machine that gets off gets a dopamine
Rush from the manipulation of other
humans yeah or the control of other
humans yeah I mean put an example of my
my own background uh my mom didn't have
a father you know she she uh he left
really early on in their in their
childhood you know my mom raised her two
sisters
and basically you kept a household uh
she was a great mom uh
she was a badass you know she was very
independent she showed me how to be
independent she showed me how to kind of
watch out for others and kind of build
me up in that way and uh I had a great
childhood as far as you know as far as
her and kind of like how she molded me
later on I figured out
that uh when I had my own kid
you know I I figured out that she was
basically trying to make me into what
she didn't have in a way
and if I can get to see somebody's
parents you know that's usually uh
that's usually a sign of uh of something
at least for me as far as figuring out
where people are I think there's
something to be said about nature and
nurture and how some people come up some
people are just born with that predatory
Instinct you know and you'll never know
I mean they spend their whole life
practicing how to hide it
uh but if you can figure out somebody's
you know background childhood where
they're from you can kind of tell
something about them you know I'm from
Tijuana you know I'm a Survivor that's
that's my background as far as where I'm
from
uh culturally genetically
psychologically
the full shebang yeah I guess some
people are born with uh certain
predispositions and if they're in the
right environment some of the negative
aspects might flourish more than others
you know for me I mean I grew up
skateboarding in Tijuana
and I remember breaking into my first uh
backyard pool it was a house that a
cartel guy owned and we used to escape
the pool in the back in the back of it
uh so I learned how to pop open padlocks
uh with a uh with a small uh vehicle
hydraulic lift
and I remember doing that and uh later
on in life I got to train with people
from other parts of Mexico and
and work with them and I remember
pulling that trick off and they were
like looking at me like where'd you
learn that like some burglars at Tijuana
you know and they're like wow that's
interesting like all all people from
Tijuana like that and I said no we're
not all like that but I guess in some
way we are because you know
Tijuana produces some produces kids like
that you know she produces like the
environment itself produces
uh produces a pretty specific person I
guess you know where our normal is our
normal or our Baseline normal is way
different than most the trajectories
that you can take in life are um are
defined in a way that aren't available
elsewhere in the world yeah and so you
develop I mean that's part of that
psychological part of that is cultural
and so on
um part of it as a cultural trauma but
then also the ethical lines based on the
corruption because I grew up in the
Soviet Union there's the same kind of
understanding that there's some gray
area of corruption yeah there's always
it's always there like in the on the
outskirts or even in the center how you
can grease things to make things easier
and how it's like it's a personal thing
I'll just you know pay off the in
Tijuana we have uh more of these as what
we call it you know when you when you
pay a cop off number that means a bite
so and uh but what's uh what's the bite
aspect so you get stopped from for a
traffic violation of some sort and the
cop walks up to you obviously you don't
say the word fight but it's like a it's
like a slang term for it and uh he asked
uh for your paperwork and you know and
if you get fined or get a ticket you say
can I pay the ticket here is what they
say
and you know put their money inside the
paperwork in hand over to the cops you
think it's you know I'm just gonna do it
and nobody knows you know but it's a
systemic thing everybody like a lot of
people do it and then they don't trust
the police because they are fed with
this
yeah I mean same thing was in the Soviet
Union it's funny but then there's
something inside you where that kind of
uh
those opportunities come like uh with a
police officer where you realize you
could just pay a little bit of money and
get out of a thing and then you realize
you can pay a little bit of money or do
a favor and get your kids in a better
school or something like that yeah but
there comes opportunities where you
where all right if if I do this little
thing I can make
I can get a huge promotion I can get a
huge increase in my power or get a lot
of money and something inside you says
no yeah it's not right yeah and I wonder
what that is that because like um
yeah I want because it feels different
than the legal systems when we operate
there's some kind of basic human
Integrity human decency I wonder if
that's like constructed or it's always
there if it's like again nature versus
nurture